Hi everyone, Spy here. This week we're doing a replay of episode 103 where Jason Huggins
joined us in an episode called The Croissants are Selenium. You all have heard my viewpoints
on UI automation and this whole episode recording came about because I was harping on some
of the ridiculousness of Selenium selector based UI automation. Jason was on the show
to both agree and defend his space. Good conversation. We're going to have Jason on
live again sometime soon. So I thought it would be a good time to share this episode,
kind of put things back into context. Again, this is episode 103. Hope you enjoy the show.
Welcome to AP Testers, the modern testing podcast. Join your hosts, Alan
and Brent. I am mindless agile robot. I must iterate.
Gah! As we talk about software engineering,
software quality, leadership and whatever else comes to mind. Now on with the show.
Hey Brent, I'm having a great day. How are you doing? I'm me too. Let's go.
Listeners may recall that listen to our last episode. We went off a little bit on UI
automation. Could you say that? It's accurate, right? I went off that that's ambiguous. I
would say we we allowed our inner passions out. We did. We did. Yeah. Again, our rants were
against UI automation, but we did refer to an enabler of that, which is Selenium and
which to our credit, we said was a super great tool, maybe too good because it enabled
people to do dumb things. And then and then stuff happened. And then we got to here.
We did. We did. And we have a very special guest today. Former ThoughtWorks employee. Oh,
hold on. Hold on. I have to I have to build up to it. I have to create drama and I need
some swelling music. By the way, Episode 103. Thank you. Welcome to the podcast.
Put a number on it. Former Google employee, former ThoughtWorks employee, current founder,
I believe, of Tapster Robotics. But for the context of our episode, we'd like to welcome
the inventor of Selenium, Jason Huggins. Well, now I can say hello. Hi. Now you can say hello.
Sorry. Yeah. Yeah, we're super excited to have you here. And Brent and I are going to sit
down and let you know. We'll we'll ask questions. We'll interact. You seem pretty
nice so far. So we're not expecting any dressing down, but we're really excited to have you here.
So thank you again for coming and talking with us today. Thanks. And I suppose as a
as a courtesy to the rest of the world, like this lets me being a guest on a podcast lets
me not start my own podcast. So I don't want to contribute to a proliferation of more things
in the world. So what part of the world are you in right now, Jason? Right now I'm in Chicago,
just west of the city and my house in Oak Park. Gotcha. Yeah. So and you are both in
the wonderful state of Washington. Yes. No, I was just thinking it because Alan ordinarily
is a fantastic technician. I'm sure he could grease the wheels for you. And if you wanted
to get a podcast going. Awesome. Yeah. I think we'd like to start off with and we'll see where
the discussion goes. Oh, this is we have no outline, which is typical for A.B. testing.
Sometimes we throw a little bit of a lean coffee list on the board. But today I just
like to start with you. You listen to episode one or two. I did. I'd like to hear your
reaction and thoughts and where we were, what you like about it and what you maybe didn't
like about it. Got it. So it's everything you said. I think like the summary is that
the punch lines you were trying to get to at the end, I totally agree with.
And it's like I there's a certain level of like a lot of the things that were said just
triggered a lot of stories in my mind. And I realized like, wow, like those stories,
not a lot of people know those stories, right? Like the project where Selenium came from or,
you know, or various things where I realized like, oh, yeah, I totally agree with that.
Like that was a horrible thing that they, you know, that the team decided to do or
other times like, no, anyway, it's just like just I just follow the stories and realize like
some of that context wasn't there. But I was glad some of the stories got through like the
story where the name came from. Right. Whatever. Anyway, and that was I
totally trying to remember. Like I heard this once. I hope this is true. I was ready to
edit that out if it wasn't. I looked it up while I was writing. Right. And so there's
this book called Made to Stick. And ironically, I don't remember much of the book. However,
it talks about all the different ways why ideas stick. And one of them apparently
was the name of Selenium and where it came from. People who were kind of in the trenches
for years with testing the fact that it was there to cure or sorry, to slay the Mercury
monster. They thought that was very humorous. But and I didn't realize I was following
following a long tradition of people very in a pun clever way or they think they're clever,
like naming something after what they think they're going against. Anyway,
but I stumbled into where I read that. I stumbled into this. I think I saw Angie Jones
tweet where she kind of oh, she was mad at me. She called you out and I was like, oh,
oh, what is this? And I saw the whole thread and like, wow, this is blowing up. And then
like, wow, OK, so listen to the whole thing. So yeah, to be fair, yes, I did feel
triggered a couple of times. We're like, wow, that's a bold statement. But then again,
you know, well, there's a certain level of it. I backed off it. I said I and the tweet
in question, like ever all the listeners have seen it said reason I hate Selenium
is because people use shitty selectors. And really, it's not Selenium. It's right.
What it enabled it. And yeah, right. Yes. This conversation could go in a
million of directions. But there's one of the things I was just thinking like
it's specifically in that context of selectors. Right. For me, my relationship
with the Selenium project, you know, we started the project in 2004. Right. So
that's a that's a lot of years. Right. And I'm not day to day on the project
anymore. Right. Simon Stewart is the leader of the project now. And so I'm
just kind of the the old guy who next to the campfire who just, you know,
has stories sitting in his rocking chair kind of thing like, hey, kid. Anyway.
Yeah. Why does it work this way? Right. Right. Well, like, can you believe this
weird sequence of events where, you know, that you pushed on this and then all of
this other stuff happened on the other side? But yeah, I don't know whether I
should just like super stay above the frame, you know, super like general or
like going to like really nitty, you know, like speaking of horrible CSS
selectors, let me tell you about that story. Anyway.
So Jason, the first thing I hear is is maybe you don't agree with the
details or where Alan pointed the finger in his tweet, but it sounds like
you agree with the sentiment. Yeah. OK. So I went back and pulled out
some quotes because and because I wanted to make sure I got this right.
And the thing was, it's like I totally agree with it, but there was
like a context that's missing. Right. So what was one of them?
Is it the one where Brent said UI automation is immoral?
Oh, I like that line. Yeah. I mean, I'm kidding. I don't like that line.
Definitely was triggered. I mean, I like it in the sense of like,
yeah, very memorable, sticky, controversial. But let me but more
specifically. So specifically, I just to make sure I'm not already being
misquoted. I said, I believe I can make that argument and I stand by that.
I was just trying to check. Yeah. Yeah.
So like, exactly. There's something about the context is the dev teams
and testing teams are separate. And I think you were was it?
Why is UI testing exists? We have to go through the top layer, blah, blah.
Why is that? Because that's where that's not what they're paid for.
This is because here's the line, because there's a separation between
testers and developers, given those worlds, so many make sense.
But I'm like, no, get rid of those worlds.
And the thing is, I totally agree with that punchline.
And so that the context that's kind of missing here is that Selenium
came from a project with no testers or no testing team, we were just
developers. And we were trying to get this app out the door.
And there's a whole context of like, we didn't have any functional
testing tool. We went months with just unit tests.
And we decided after months of headache and frustration, a very specific
technical problems where things were breaking in one browser and fixed
in the other. And Brent, you mentioned this like, hey, in the
cross browser testing context, that makes sense.
So at the time, this was like Firefox and IE, IE 6.
And Firefox before it was even 1.0, it was like 0.8.
Anyway, so we as a developer team with no testing, no testers,
and no separate testing team, that's why we created this tool.
And so and I've spent my career like, kind of avoiding those
situations where there's a separate siloed testing team.
And I think maybe like where I felt compelled to kind of like, you know,
put up my hand and be on the show because I feel like I'm
you're arguing for a thing that I've actually I feel like I've
spent all my time kind of trying to stay in there.
Like I kind of know about and I feel like you're also in that same
spot where there is dysfunction and having these separate teams and you're
actively trying to avoid that as well and bring people along saying like,
doesn't have to be this way, right?
So in that sense, we're like very spiritually aligned, right?
But what I think I see and it's not so much your words, but I think
I definitely see this as a trend is people are forgetting that
Sonium started as a developer tool, like for developers by developers
kind of thing.
And I say that specifically because it's kind of an annoying tagline.
But it's ironically like this Cypress team, the Cypress other,
the testing tool, they're specifically using that as a marketing
tool against Sonium is like, well, Cypress is this quote, unquote,
you know, real for real developers, whatever.
So there's this weird thing where there's this trend and again,
like architecturally, it's literally the implement, like everything that
was in Sonium one, the version that was like 15 years old,
everything about Cypress is how we did that first version.
And basically I threw it all away and we merged with Simon's
WebDriver project to make Sonium two.
So not only like do they not know their history, like they really
don't know their history.
Anyway, and the marketing line, like that was my marketing line,
which is basically kind of like what punks do when they're trying to
make some noise, right?
But there's, but I got some criticism at the very beginning by
creators of other testing tools saying that Sonium was too geeky.
The only kind of selectors we actually kind of, Alan,
you mentioned this, like, you know, add a unique ID or data ID.
That was the only thing that Sonium supported at the beginning.
And when people would say that like, oh, you should support all
these other things, like I was kind of ambivalent.
Like, yeah, sure, go ahead, knock yourself out, go do it.
But when I use this tool, I'm going to go in the source code,
modify it, make it so there's ID tags and whatever.
So it came from like this really, like it was actually like
really not usable by most testers and testing teams.
And it kind of was actively avoiding kind of working on
projects where there was like, where there was a separate
siloed testing scene.
So what I've seen, though, is testing.
Sorry, go ahead.
No, I see.
And then it got out of control.
You lost that.
Yeah, I think what happened right is that the, you know,
I don't know what metaphor I'm looking for at the moment,
but the testers and testing teams are getting kind of pushed
out of the nest, if you will, right?
I kind of look at it like in two different directions.
There's a whole bunch of people.
They want to stay employed, rightfully so.
And so they're pushed into writing more code and
writing automation.
And that's kind of where they end up at the
Sonium meetups and Sonium conferences, because like
they're being pushed either pulled or pushed or whatever
to like learn this thing, keep their job.
If nothing else, like, you know, learn automation,
become a coder.
And then there's another side where I think it's
totally a fine path.
But I think it's maybe harder to find people talking
about this and arguing about it at conferences,
things like that, but like a business analyst
where you're sitting at a dashboard and like you're
looking at like Google Analytics or some kind of
thing where you're kind of you're sitting there
with a kind of a clipboard and you're kind of more
kind of as an analysis to maybe figuring out what
needs to get tested.
You're not writing code, but you're kind of like
looking at the system as a whole.
I think that's a totally valid track for testers.
And I think what's going away is just like people just,
you know, sitting there clicking a button.
Right.
And unfortunately, those kind of jobs stick around
is because management in some level thinks that
testing is sitting there clicking a button.
Right.
So they put out a job, correct?
Like you need a button clicker.
There's actually so I don't know if you're
much of a reader.
We just we just met.
Have you heard of Nancy Forgren's book Accelerate?
I have not.
I am a reader, but I have not read that.
OK, I definitely recommend.
It's Nicole Forsgren.
Is it Nicole?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Nicole, she she keynoted the the sauce conference.
Oh, you know what?
I think I quoted her as Nancy at the webinar yesterday as well.
Sorry, it's Nicole Forsgren.
I'm just going to call her Dr.
Forsgren.
I think I got the last name.
Got it.
Anyway, so she's spent the last four years
looking at certain constructs, particularly lean and agile type of constructs.
But it's studying it, researching it.
And this book is sort of the published results of her research.
And one of the things that she came out and stated is
Dev owning the the testing and the automation of the tests
is correlated with positive business outcomes.
But interestingly enough, test owning and maintaining it
is not correlated with business outcomes.
I, about 10 years ago, left the QA job, went to dev.
Like you did not have a test team.
And I completely from experience, I completely see why, right?
Once you have the dev team owning it, they don't like like everyone else.
They don't like maintaining test automation.
And what you find is that they naturally build stronger test designs
to make it easier for them to keep the quality high, keep the system moving.
Yeah, I guess I do have to push back just on a little bit, like be an annoying person here
in the sense of like setting up an us versus them kind of dichotomy there.
I feel like I think it gets the clicks in the views.
But I think I'm kind of sitting there imagining someone who's in that testing role.
And through no fault of their own, they're trying to figure out what's their kind of next move, right?
If they're now thinking like, oh, wow, okay, my role is not going to lead to business success.
I'm thinking like, okay, let's not divide.
Well, because you're not don't have the title developer.
Let's find a way to like forget the labels for a second.
Let's actually get to that.
Okay, what causes business success, right?
Regardless of title or role or whatever, what can that person do?
What's some tangible thing that they can do?
So if you have an opportunity, I'll do a pitch.
Go back and listen to the AB testing podcast, say starting around episode 80.
This is actually what the modern testing principles.
What was that number again?
80.
80, start at 80.
Vintage.
All right.
So one of the things that is a big passion for Alan and I
is we actually think that the world is very rapidly changing.
We're seeing a lot of studies that sort of agree with this.
It's even more than what you started talking about earlier where
we see, you know, test is a bunch of button clickers, right?
So that's been an issue ever since I've been in this career.
But now we're seeing the reason why I brought up Dr.
Forsgren's analysis is it will further solidify the opinion of folks like that
because now we have an expert claiming proof of it.
So what Alan and I are doing, we actually believe that these
testers are extremely talented and valuable people.
But we do see a threat pending sometime soonish.
And that could be measured in decades, but we see this rapidly accelerating.
And so what we're trying to do is reach them and say,
hey, start investing yourself.
Start finding a new role.
One of my favorite ways of describing this is you can either be the butterfly
or you can be the wind.
We need people to recognize that this is a possibility.
And hey, if we're wrong, they've invested in themselves and they've grown themselves.
If we're right, then they still won't be part of the calling, I guess, for lack of a better word.
I guess we're, again, where I felt compelled to say, hey, okay, let's talk.
I got kind of that gist of that, again, kind of a random metaphor coming out of my brain.
It sounded like you were sitting in a cafe in England
complaining about the croissants and saying, gosh, I can't wait to get out of England.
Let's get to France and we'll never have to deal with croissants anymore, right?
Because metaphorically, croissants are selenium.
Anyway, and so there's a certain feeling of I'm sitting here going,
I'm sitting in France thinking, wow, I'm surrounded by
all these croissants or selenium or whatever my metaphor is.
I hope it's making sense.
But there's a certain level of that.
I totally get this whole encouraging, empowering testers.
But I guess I'm here to say selenium is on the other side.
It's on the other side, right?
It's there.
And I guess that was the point.
So I guess the show's over now.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
There are croissants in France is what I'm trying to say.
I'm getting hungry.
I'm working.
Okay, wait, who's the croissant?
Is selenium the croissant?
What are we saying?
Selenium the croissant.
You were saying, if we can just get rid of the selenium stuff
and get testers into more awesome, follow these principles, right?
Then no more selenium.
And I'm here to say, actually, when you're following all those principles,
selenium came out of that environment.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So if what we said last episode got interpreted that way, yeah, that's false.
But I also kind of agree in the sense of,
I think this is the true of any, dare I say it, popular thing, right?
Selenium's popular, but so are PHP, right?
Like any kind of popular language or framework or whatever,
eventually, there's a lot of low-hanging fruit to make fun of, right?
Because there's so many people doing bad things with it.
And so there's a certain level of like, it's a big target.
So let's make sure that everyone listening is on the same page.
I think all of us agree selenium is a great tool.
And I think all of us agree several great tools
will encourage really bad ways of using them.
Right.
Metaphorically, croissants are made with a stick of butter,
and that'll super spike your cholesterol,
so you shouldn't actually eat croissants.
But they're delicious.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Mmm, butter.
Well, if croissants were originally,
and by the way, the title of this episode is going to be,
the croissants are selenium.
I think that happens.
I hope this metaphor makes sense.
But they're really bad for you.
You should have, you know.
It's like saying the croissants are,
I mean, the croissants came out of a place
where they were for a certain type of people,
and they've been adopted.
Now, everyone's eating the croissants,
and they're eating them wrong.
They're eating them all the time, maybe, is the...
Maybe, they're eating them too much.
You're supposed to eat croissants at the proper time.
And coming out of the environment you built it out of,
and people are like, what?
And our French listeners are going, what?
These guys are so wrong.
Ooh la la.
The croissants are a lie.
Okay.
All right.
Next time, I won't bring up food right before lunch.
Sorry.
I guess our argument is that we're highly aligned
on where selenium came out of,
and I think developers that use selenium
use it very responsibly and well.
Like, if you're a developer and you end up,
best way for me to test this is through the,
is via the web page, I'm going to go do this,
and you end up, you would never settle as a developer
for going, yep, this selector looks fine.
You would go add an ID for it and make the code look good.
The problem is, I mentioned this before,
is that what's happened is selenium is being used
as a way for testers to learn the code,
to write code, to...
But working in a siloed environment sometimes,
they end up being totally happy.
Like, this is the way you do it.
You write selectors like this,
I just right click and copy out of dev tools,
and I get this thing that looks like gibberish,
but that's how I write my automation,
and it ends up being super fragile.
And by that automation being fragile,
they now have a job maintaining automation,
and now their entire job is maintaining automation,
and we think that's a really, really bad thing.
Right.
Let me add...
Yeah, and that's where I think I agree, totally agree.
So Jason, you said that the current,
the selector model that Alan's referring to
wasn't a feature when it was still in your control?
Right. I mean, if you go back to,
I think the very first...
I'm not sure if even CSS selectors
were even a spec back in 2004.
Someone's going to look that up and see when it came out.
I wouldn't be surprised if like 2007, 2008,
or something like that.
The moral equivalence,
or immoral equivalence of CSS selectors
was XPath at the time.
That was the first thing that I think
may be one of the next things that came after.
No, that's so...
When I was using Selenium, that's what I was doing,
and it drove me batty.
Right, and given your...
I could guess why.
Because XPath was native code in Firefox and Safari,
and all the browsers except Internet Explorer.
And so we had to emulate XPath selector kind of stuff.
We had to use a JavaScript library in IE,
which meant, I think it increased the time of execution
by like a hundredfold or something ridiculous, right?
And anyway, so like...
Can I share a story?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Got it.
So there's this one thing where, Alan,
you were kind of pointing out of like, yeah,
just like, well, you should use IDs.
The one thing I felt very triggered was like,
there's this one time when I was at Google,
and I was talking with the Google Maps team,
and they were using XPath to get to all of the...
They were actually testing Google Maps, obviously,
but there were all the map tiles,
you know, like go from one location to the other.
And there's all these different kind of,
how do you test a global map tool?
It's a very specific case,
but also there's some crazy corner cases, right?
And I just went in there, as I usually do,
and say, well, if the XPath stuff is not working,
don't use it.
Put ID tags everywhere and just test that.
And they're like, if we add an ID tag
to every map tile at every elevation,
we will increase the storage required for Google Maps
by like, you know, 5, 10X or something.
And that was already a pretty big number to start with, right?
So I realized, oh, okay, that's bad advice.
And so through process of kind of elimination,
I realized they had to use XPath.
There was no other...
Because they couldn't instrument the code.
So, you know, that was part of like one of my jobs
when I was there of like helping them figure out
how to make things go faster.
No, it didn't cross anybody's mind to like,
let's just not test it.
What's the money ever do to any browser testing?
There was a certain level of like,
no, it's given that we will do this browser testing.
Their specific problem though is like,
because once they run it in IE,
the tests were taking forever.
But they ended up having to get to the closest location
before you jump into all the map tiles
where you kind of get to like its parent element,
like a div or something like that.
And then from there, then you start navigating children
and like go forward three steps to go to the left,
back up one.
And that was the selector and it was super annoying.
I think the project years later, so anyway,
end of random anecdote of Google Maps,
but like it's a problem
and sometimes you can't really do the right thing, I guess.
But we jumped to kind of recommending CSS selectors
years later because for one, under the hood,
in whatever version of IE came out,
it was also natively implemented.
So if you switch to that,
we didn't have to kind of shim in a JavaScript library
to do that.
So like people just naturally moved from Xpath to CSS.
But again, either way,
either of those things are not ideal.
Ideally, you would go after some kind of unique tag
to make it like super clear.
Anyway, but it really came down
to like the browser implementations
and what was faster over time CSS selectors
kind of became faster.
But yeah, people, when they start doing kind of like,
find the parent element, go down five children,
it becomes very much like, you know,
you're telling instructions to someone who's blindfolded,
like, okay, turn left, go forward three paces, turn right.
Like that's, yeah, that's ridiculous.
Yeah, that won't scale.
No, the thing is, is-
But if you're on the Google Maps team,
then you might have to do that.
Well, no, no, no.
I mean, for every rule,
there's exceptions that are valid, right?
The thing I'm wondering right now,
and we kind of did last episode
under the assumption it's dominant,
but the thing I'm wondering right now
is the CSS style, the way everyone automates
with Selenium.
No, it's not the way everyone automates.
Is it dominant?
Oh, actually, I would love to ask you this.
So you were saying like, tools can enable like gold
or I forgot to write it down,
but basically like you can do an awesome thing
or you can do kind of crap, right?
But a different kind of tool
can maybe add some safety rails there.
So it actually kind of prevents
the ability to do that bad thing, right?
Completely agree.
So in that context, I'm curious,
was it a mistake to put the CSS selectors in there
or would it be an improvement?
I don't know how to phrase this question,
but like if we have an opinion
on the correct way to do it
or the incorrect way to do it,
let's say CSS selectors,
should CSS selectors as a way of finding elements,
should that be removed from the tool?
If it gets abused so much,
should that be removed?
It can't at this stage
because I think whether it's dominant or not,
we all agree that these siloed test teams,
these separate test teams,
are not a great way to make software,
but I think that's where selenium is being used a lot
and these teams, sometimes the only way for them to,
sometimes they don't even have an option
to communicate with the developers
and ask them to ask the ID tags.
Right, which is just sad.
That is very sad.
Yes, yeah, it breaks my heart.
It's sad.
Well, the one I'm more worried about
is the one where there's a negative relationship
between the test and dev teams
and dev is not adding the device IDs
and we get feedback along those lines
and test says, okay, we'll screw you,
I'll go with CSS or the stylesheet approach
and work around the fact
that you're not helping us do the right thing.
Of course, it's a missed opportunity
to ask the question like,
should we even have tests at all?
Or at least at this level, right?
Yes, oh, yes.
I was setting you up for you to totally,
I was setting up the straw man.
You didn't take my bait.
Well, I was thinking about it earlier
so I'm going to ask you this question
and actually this is really good
because we can talk about the origins of selenium again
and these stories are all great.
You can just tell random stories about selenium
as much as you want and we'll fit them in
but the question I want to ask is
work with development teams using selenium
my hypothesis and my experience anecdotally
is that when dev teams own those selenium tests
they're actually very good about writing
only the tests they need
versus trying to automate everything with selenium
which unfortunately these we see more often
these silo test teams what they try and do.
So how did, what are some heuristics you used
to figure out what you would test in selenium
and what you wouldn't?
What I would test with selenium, what I wouldn't.
I used to give a little talks about this
trying to mentally remind myself of all my little slideshows.
The number one thing would be
I think there's like failure modes, right?
That someone kind of gets super enthusiastic
and they just test anything that moves, right?
So I've got lots of opinions on this
but I can also kind of go back to
what we did originally like why it existed.
Wait, wait, wait, Jason
why would we not test the things that don't move?
Whoa.
Yeah, right.
Okay, just broke my brain.
I'm going to ignore that question.
Yeah, fair enough.
So it started as a,
it really was from a regression point of view.
The very specific thing,
I call this like the sine wave of quality
where the reason why it was basically pencils down,
screw this, we are going to solve this problem
and then selenium came out of it was
this dumb little button in Firefox is working
and then someone did something to it,
forgot what it was
but it would break it in Internet Explorer.
And so the bug report would be it's broken in IE, fix it.
So they go and do that.
They push it in, we push it to production
of course, they've now broken it in Firefox, right?
So the next week we support,
we put in a bug saying Firefox is broken.
This little button in Firefox is broken, fix it.
So they go in and fix it.
When they test it in Firefox,
we push it to production and what happens?
It's now broken in IE.
So there was this like,
we were not making any progress
and we were regressing, right?
And so I kind of,
I forced this as a kind of like a no retreat,
kind of like sometimes there's a different metaphor,
like a ratchet.
Like you're kind of moving up and up
on like a roller coaster, right?
It keeps you from back sledding, right?
No, it sounds like you were on a merry-go-round.
What was that?
I said, it sounds like you were on a merry-go-round.
Or the caffeine is just finally kicking in, right?
Yeah.
It was just, yeah, right.
Oh, right.
The project felt whatever.
It was a circle.
Time is a flat circle, right?
It was very frustrating.
And so I kind of went with this observation, if you will,
not an opinion just observing the team collectively
that you tell them to fix it in Firefox,
to fix it in Firefox because they're good developers,
but they're not covering every base.
And so we said like, let's automate this for one.
And then two, like, let's solve it.
So over time, over the first couple of months
of Selenium kind of being on the project,
we were finding little cases like that,
or we were kind of sort of backsliding.
Like we fixed one thing,
but we break something over there.
And so initially, basically the test names
were kind of tracked to like whatever random regression
bug ID that they were linked to, right?
And I don't see this actually a lot in a lot of teams.
They kind of are more upfront, right?
So here's a feature.
What's the automated test for that feature?
And there you go, right?
So over time, we eventually,
as new features were being created,
again, because the Selenium project came,
there were six months of development
before we had any user interface tool,
which of course is kind of potentially mind blowing
of like maybe that was a good thing.
I don't know.
Like maybe all projects should go six months
and then do Selenium tests later.
If they like maybe they're like,
maybe that's the prognosis.
Like don't do anything day one,
wait three months and then see if you need it, right?
I don't know.
But the other thing,
eventually we added like new feature tests,
but we got a lot of value.
I got personally as like the project manager
of this thing, like, and whatever,
like I could finally see the team was not backsliding.
And so kind of a regression testing point of view,
but also like in that context of like
cross browser regression testing,
making sure that when you,
we were specifically doing something on one browser,
we weren't inadvertently breaking something
on the other side of the room, right?
And I kind of, I get value in that.
But in that bigger context of what you're asking,
like, right, kind of we,
there was a million other kinds of ways
that we could do it, but, you know,
given that we had limited resources,
we kind of focused on those kinds of tests
that we thought were the most useful.
When I give kind of this little speech to other people,
I also kind of say like,
you're going to write tests ahead of time,
or actually it doesn't matter the context,
but if you're going to like to start from zero,
what would you test?
And one would be like the money path, I call it, right?
The, there's some path.
One, step one, whatever you're doing,
hopefully it's making money.
If it's not, solve that problem.
Don't go write a bunch of selenium tests
if your startup is-
The more we automate, the more we'll make.
Right, and so like A,
find money somehow, you know,
either profits or grants
or however you want to do it, right?
And then there is a money path, right?
So maybe don't spend so much time
writing an entire framework around,
you know, changing the color settings
or your header profile or your foot,
but there is a path where people can swipe a credit card
and give you money and sign up for the thing, right?
So if you're going to start somewhere,
focus on that
and then you kind of build things around it.
Sometimes there's this metaphor,
it's not my metaphor, but very cliched.
Like it's kind of like paving the cow paths, right?
Where you kind of look where people are going
and then that's where you figure out
where to put the site, the concrete for the sidewalks.
I look at that, but it's also like following where,
where people,
like what's the most valuable path
through your application and start there.
Eventually, maybe over time,
you go to the lesser used paths.
But again, if it's kind of a focused developer team,
maybe they don't get to it.
You touched on something I want you to
set me straight on if needed, probably needed.
I haven't used Selenium in about three years,
but the last project I used it on
was a project using Angular back at Microsoft.
And we had, and again, kudos to Jim Evans
for trying to make that IE WebDriver work.
I think he's done some great work.
I'm not sure where that was at the time,
but we had a really hard time with our Selenium test
getting them to run across Chrome, IE, Firefox, and Safari.
Right. Yeah, that's unfortunate, right?
Because it was started to be that, right?
So it's like, it's not living up to its raison d'etre.
If that was like in that moment,
like it needed to be a cross browser tool.
Yeah, because that's where we see,
like the story used to describe,
like if you want to make sure these elements
continue to work across browsers, super powerful.
But there is a parallel universe here.
Like, so there's from like a, you know,
correct way, like if I'm meditating on that phrase
of like they solve the wrong problem really well, right?
One way that we could have solved that problem well,
in a completely different way,
is John Resig created the jQuery project, right?
Same goal was JavaScript is super buggy cross browser.
And so it created one API
that if you write to the jQuery API,
then you've solved your cross browser problems.
Very elegant solution to the same problem,
completely different context, right?
So like there's a different kind of recommendation there,
right, is not so much use jQuery,
but there's a certain level like find ways
to avoid the cross browser testing problem
without necessarily throwing all the weight
at the selenium level or the testing level, right?
Maybe there's a different framework you can use
or just give up, quit, go hiking across the country
and give up all the way.
No, I mean, I'm actually thinking, so there's,
I see a move, I don't know if this is going to take off,
but I see a lot of browser companies basing on Chrome now,
and I wonder if essentially that sort of standardization
is going to keep pushing forward
to what degree that will eliminate cross browser.
Yeah, I sadly am, I don't want to speak for you guys,
but like there's a certain,
I guess I'm now at risk of being that guy
who's seen this, the business cycles,
and now I'm in the corner saying,
we've done this all before, like,
basically like note one, no one listens to that guy,
but the person, that guy or girl is also totally right,
right, like where everything is a fad,
everything's been done before.
There's a certain level of like,
so if nothing else, like to your point,
like there's kind of browser consolidation,
everyone's kind of like choose,
like getting on the bandwagon,
it's all going to be Chrome.
I would look at it saying like, well,
inevitably Google will become like Microsoft
and realize it has all the power of the universe
and go super evil,
and then naturally some Firefox-like thing
will come out of that and punch the air,
like shake their fists,
kind of like give a Braveheart speech
and say Google is evil,
we're going to do this other thing,
and it will effectively,
there'll be another 10 years, 15 years of the Firefox,
there'll be a new Firefox
that will fight the old evil Chrome.
This is like inevitable, right?
So I'm not too worried about Chrome,
like a kind of a monoculture around Chrome
because if it gets too much of a problem,
it will then, history will repeat itself
and then there will be kind of a blossoming
of a bunch of options.
But right now we're in kind of a consolidation mode
and that's just, I don't know,
I guess I just look at it,
it's like, I guess it's maybe a problem,
but I'm not so fired up about it.
Got you.
Magically, somehow it'll solve itself in 10 years,
I guess is what I'm trying to say.
In hindsight, I'm wondering,
I have two thoughts in my head,
I'll see if I can keep them straight.
But one thing I'm wondering is
if those Selenium tests we had were just,
I mean, they were fairly simple,
but maybe too complex.
Maybe what you want to test there is
for cross browser compatibility,
I'm wondering if there is some heuristic around
writing simple tests
and the simpler the test is
or the less crazy you try and get,
maybe the more apt that test is to run,
successfully across browsers.
Yeah, it sounds like we could
put a consulting hat on there,
I'd love to dive down
and specifically see the lines of code
and see why is it working here and not there.
And to be fair, it's been three years
and there's so much progress on all fronts
on the WebDriver projects that it's...
No, thanks to me, absolutely not.
Like this is all thanks to Jim and Simon
and there's a million other people
that are day to day in the trenches
working on the project now.
The other thought in my head is
because of the Braveheart quote,
now I'm wondering if that's where
the Brave browser got their name from.
I don't know.
Which Braveheart quote?
Oh, I was just imagining,
in my mind, I was just imagining,
was it, I'm blanking out his name,
but it's the actor,
Mel Gibson, like just standing on his horse,
just encouraging people to go into battle.
I can't even remember why I was saying.
Anyway, it was the rallying cry.
Yeah, right, right, right.
Yeah, someone's going to have some rallying cries
saying we need to fight these browsers.
Whatever.
Where were we?
You're asking two old guys
who can't remember where they park their cars.
I don't know.
Well, so the one thing
that Jason started talking about
reminded me of...
I can just sense so many people
rolling their eyes listening to this right now.
We expected a fight.
No, the...
I am the steel...
I am the top Google search
for steel cage knife fight, by the way.
I want to point that out.
You are? Why?
Well, it's a funny story.
So everyone, stop what you're doing,
Google the phrase steel cage knife fight.
And the story there was...
This was the Google test automate...
I totally cut you off, Brent.
I'm sorry.
No, no, it's fine.
Story time.
This was the Google test automation conference 2007.
So this is Google's second test conference.
And there's a whole awesome backstory
on even why Google did this test conference
for a couple of years.
And I've got some conspiracy theories
on why they stopped doing it.
But anyway, not important to the story.
So I'm there in New York City
and I was drafted in to give a talk to replace a speaker.
At that time, I was a Googler.
I'd been there for six months.
Simon Stewart was still at ThoughtWorks
and I had just left ThoughtWorks the year before.
He was there to present WebDriver.
And I had seen WebDriver
when we were both at ThoughtWorks a year earlier.
And anyways, I was ready to not be impressed by his talk.
And also, there were a lot of Selenium talks at GTAC.
And also, I was super awkward and weird about it, right?
Because I didn't realize it was being used that much.
Anyway, so I was sitting through Simon's talk
and I realized he had fixed...
I'm kind of sitting there with crossed arms thinking like,
OK, waiting to take notes and shoot everything down.
And he had fixed all of the problem.
Every conceptual, architectural, whatever you want to call it,
idea that I was against WebDriver and how he did things.
He fixed all those problems
and it was awesome and brilliant.
In an instant, as I'm watching his talk about WebDriver,
I realized this is it.
This really is the Selenium killer.
This is all the things I would wish we could do
in a future version of Selenium.
So then I had kind of a choice there.
It could either be my new best friend
or I could find some weird passive-aggressive way
to super hate on him, right?
Because he's clearly made the better tech.
So these were our presentations, right?
The other footnote to history, my talk was
I created an AWS account two days before
and got access to like 20 machines in the cloud.
And I wondered if I could run a browser test in the cloud.
I thought that would be interesting.
And this is like 2007, right?
So that was actually AWS had only been around
for maybe six months or a year at that point.
So this was like a new thing in the world.
Anyway, side note to that thing.
But the reason why Steelcage and I fight,
long story long,
they were lightning talks at the very last day.
And so I proposed kind of as a way to encourage this.
He's either figuring out whether he's my new best friend
or my new enemy.
I proposed doing a dueling lightning talk
where we would both talk about Selenium and WebDriver
as a kind of set it up as a debate.
Kind of like in Wink and Douglass debate
or something like that, whatever.
But with the caveat where I would have to argue
for and against WebDriver and he would have to argue
or I would have to argue for like five reasons
why WebDriver is awesome and Selenium is horrible.
That would be my side.
And then Simon would stand up there
and give five reasons why WebDriver is horrible
and Selenium is awesome, right?
So we would like flip sides, arguably, whatever.
Anyway, so the thing was that conversation
and I can't believe he went along with it
and we did this thing.
But there was like a lot of ha ha,
I'm serious kind of conversations of like,
well, what if we merged projects, right?
What if we joined forces?
And so that it kind of started at that,
you know, GTAC 2007 New York City.
That's where the WebDriver,
like the idea of WebDriver joining this Selenium project
started.
And it started with kind of like, yeah,
this very kind of joke and idea of like,
let's do a steel cage knife bite where of course
it comes out that we're just all friends, right?
No, I think that was brilliant.
Particularly, you know, if you felt beforehand
that WebDriver was the better product,
which is what I heard, right?
You're like, let's set up the game so I win.
Well done.
Well, there was a specific idea that he implemented
that I kind of like, oh, that was the wrong idea.
There was something in the water,
like with there's an older framework idea
called FIT, Framework for Integrated Testing.
Ward Cunningham, more famous for creating,
right, right, more famous for creating Wikipedia,
or sorry, not Wikipedia, but the Wiki.
But then there was other projects that are out there
where they're kind of running with this idea.
And even with the first version of Selenium,
also kind of ran with the idea for implementing FIT.
My first, my one and only maybe email to Ward Cunningham
was like, has anyone done FIT for JavaScript?
If not, great, I'm going to go do that, right?
So that was like part of its tagline.
And I realized at some point later, like, wow,
that was like a bad idea to do that.
Especially if it's a developer tool,
like if you're writing a developer tool for developers,
they would rather write in Python or Java
or C Sharp or whatever.
They don't want to write in HTML tables
or something like that, right?
It was kind of ridiculous.
But there are other frameworks that are still out there
that still use that.
And when I first saw Simon's first implementation
of WebDriver, he was also kind of doing
that first kind of user interface or facade into it
was like a fit like we had to write your tests and tables
and we're like, ah, man, here we go again.
But when he gave that presentation in New York,
he got rid of all of that.
He just got to like the chocolatey goodness
of the stuff and the like just footnote to history.
But the specific thing was Selenium 1,
like at that time, the state of the art for Selenium,
everything was emulated in JavaScript.
Again, same way that Cypress is implemented now.
It's all injected JavaScript in the browser.
And Simon solved it kind of at the operating system level
where you would ask the operating system
to click a button or something like that.
So as far as the browser is from the browser's perspective,
the events were more native and less flaky
or something like that.
Anyway, I'm getting super in the weeds here.
But where were we?
One thing I wanted to mention
and then I'll ask for probably some closing comments
from you or anyone you can get to.
I went to maybe the last,
I think it was the next to the last GTAC conference.
Yeah.
And ironically, I may actually be using that word
correctly in this case.
Or yeah, I nicknamed it the flaky test conference
because every single talk had some flavor
of talking about how to deal with flaky tests.
Right.
And I think it's just interesting
that came up in my head while you were talking.
I don't know why you need to,
I mean, it's one slide.
It just says the word delete.
Right.
What I find fascinating was why Google
started that series of conferences.
The first one was LTAC.
So it was the London Test Automation Conference.
Alan Hutchison based in the New York,
or sorry, in the London office there.
Here's the thing about the whole GTAC conference.
Secretly it was,
oh, what they were finding was that
it's really hard to find developers
who are interested in testing.
So this was a way of flushing people out in the world
of the self-identify as people
who are just totally geek out on this stuff.
Right.
It's really hard to find that developer,
test-minded developer, if you will.
So for a couple of years, it was secretly,
secretly, very secretly on the lowdown,
kind of a recruiting effort for Google.
Right.
At some point, the cat was out of the bag
and it became obviously a recruiting thing.
So why would people then send their employees
off to a Google conference
to then just be poached and then leave?
Right.
So once that was obvious, it was impossible.
Who's going to go?
If you're not already a Googler,
why would you send your employees there?
Right.
But there was a good couple of,
there was some beautiful years there at the beginning
where there really wasn't a developer
really geeky, really nerdy in the weeds.
Let's just tons and tons of code,
developer-focused testing conference.
The other kind of context here was like,
I didn't even know when we started Selenium
that testing was a profession,
that there were books,
that there were conferences
and all kinds of things like that.
So kind of leading like in forms,
and I would only go to developer conferences
like JSConf or PyCon or things like that.
Only after a couple of years,
I finally went to see testing conferences
like Star East, Star West,
or SDPCon, things like that.
But Alan was specifically trying to find developer,
test-minded developers, if you will.
And he felt like there wasn't a lot of real
in the weed, gnarly geekiness.
So to fix stuff like you asked,
yes, you could delete it.
I think in 2007, I completely agree with that.
I think, I don't think that's...
Back in 2007, like 12 years ago,
yeah, I completely agree with that.
The separation of roles was a big thing
at a lot of companies.
Microsoft still had a test team, right?
For sure.
They had almost 10,000 testers at that time.
So finding test-minded developers.
Matter of fact, I think 2007 is even
sort of pre the dominance of TDD
and sort of design constructs
that now are very popular in the industry.
So I don't think that world exists today.
I wonder how often or to what degree I'm right.
I'm thinking, again, putting myself
in the seat of the listener here,
and I'm just thinking like listening
to myself tell all these wonderful,
cool stories, which I thought was a good idea.
Maybe it is.
I don't know.
Probably not.
But I'm thinking like, okay,
was there any actionable thing going forward?
Like, okay, now we know what the industry
was like a couple of years ago.
Like, yeah, now what?
So what?
Okay, go eat croissants.
That's the moral of the story.
So actually, yeah, so it's time for us to close,
but why don't you...
Here's a suggestion.
Jason, do you have any regrets
around how Selenium is being used today,
or do you have any guidance around how...
So again, I mentioned, I think I can make an argument
it's immoral, or it's UI automation
to some degree is immoral.
And yes, that's hyperbole,
but I think all three of us know
that that is non-tribially true
when we look at it from a business context.
Anything you want to mention on that regrets,
like, is there one thing,
if you had an audience to tell testers,
hey, please stop doing this with my baby,
what would you want to say?
Oh, man.
And that could be anything.
It doesn't have to be even related
to what we talked about today.
I guess I would just say,
web testing is just so yesterday,
it's all about robots right now.
Stop.
Really, I've got a lot to say on that stuff,
I don't know how to put a bow on that.
There's a certain level of like,
I'm that dangerous engineer who,
that whole like, they spent so much time
figuring out how they could do it,
they don't spend enough time deciding,
figuring out, spending enough time
thinking about whether they should.
I put myself in this role where it's like,
where I look, I get motivated
when someone tells me something is impossible.
Selenium came from a time
where people said it is impossible
to test JavaScript, right?
And I rejected that.
And so Selenium came from like,
the massive motivation was like,
ta-da, here it is.
Here is a tool that you can use
to test JavaScript, right?
I wanted to win that argument.
It's a completely different argument,
but it needs to happen on whether you should,
I want to kind of take off the table,
you shouldn't do it because you can't do it.
I feel like that is not a great argument.
It can shut down conversations for sure,
but I don't like that.
I would rather encourage people to say,
assuming we can do it,
and assuming we can totally do it well,
we can solve that problem really well.
Should we be solving that problem, right?
And this is where we totally agree.
Find that higher level above the browsers.
Should we be writing a web app?
Should it be a mobile app?
Should we be making an app at all, right?
Try to find that.
And maybe some of these decisions
kind of come out of it.
**Jade,** So you mentioned robots.
One of our listeners asked a question
on Slack the other day,
and one of the opinion,
hey, specifically,
do we think AI is going to kill Selenium?
Now, I essentially said a very long worded version of
not anytime soon.
But what's your thoughts?
**Matt,** So this is interesting.
No, I don't think it will,
because it's like an overhyped word
that means everything and nothing right now.
So there's no way anything
could possibly live up to this hype, right?
Unless by killing Selenium,
it kills half the planet and therefore,
some kind of doomsday terminator scenario.
We're like, well, yeah,
technically as an afterthought, right?
After effect, whatever.
So a couple of years ago,
I had this idea,
and I guess I didn't think to put AI
in the word of it
because it wasn't this buzzword thing.
But I thought like,
you know what definitely needs to stop happening
is people spending their whole day
staring at the Selenium API
and trying to figure out
how to craft the perfect test.
And I thought it would be more useful use of time
to maybe look at Google analytical data,
see where like basically
that's that cow paths metaphor.
Find where people are going,
which kind of means like
put stuff out in production
and see how people are using it
and then use that to inform how you should test.
But then take it one step further.
If it now like if there's like this path
that's emerging
because you've kind of instrumented things,
why don't you just have that spit out
the Selenium test suite for you, right?
It's effectively converting a log file
to a Selenium test.
And then taking it one step further,
not even like doing anything.
You could stop there and say,
okay, download your Selenium test suite
and install it into your CI.
But how about you go one step further beyond that
and it automatically runs
basically today's production code
against your newest version
that's in source control,
but you haven't pushed to production yet, right?
And so then you start doing
kind of like an A-B test, if you will,
of like, okay, you know, production,
we had roughly this number of paths
to sign up for credit cards and whatever,
run all effectively this log data
against our production candidate.
And as long as things aren't grossly out of bounds,
then that's like it vaguely seems like we've tested things
like we haven't broken anything
and push that to production.
And it basically get to a point
where no one opened an IDE
and looked at the Selenium or the WebDriver API
and wrote a test.
Like the system wrote those tests.
There is a patent out there.
It's called, I thought it was rather clever,
analytics-driven development.
So I patented ADD.
And it's this idea that you would take
this analytical data
and you would generate test cases
and then use those automatically
to test your stuff that's out there.
And I would argue that, well,
that's like a machine learning algorithm.
That is AI.
And so does that kill Selenium?
No, like under the hood,
you would still have some automation engine
that would run steps that automate a browser.
So that doesn't go away.
And if anything else, because-
But the human screwing it up does.
Yeah, maybe.
But you're going to screw things up
in awesome new ways.
So it ends up being like all technology.
It will now be pushed down
into a lower level of the stack
that we're barely aware of.
And there's these metaphors
about leaky abstractions or something.
It'll be something like we're
almost like compiling to assembly.
It's there.
Someone super wants to geek out.
They might have to pop the hood
and go down there.
But people will be spending
all their time kind of manipulating
machine learning kind of data sets
of like, oh, how do we replicate
production data
before we push to production?
Like, oh, well, maybe find-
There'll be all these arguments
about how do we basically coach
again, from a cow paths metaphor,
how can we maybe herd
these virtual animals,
whatever you want to call it.
How can we modify-
How do we create these data sets?
How do we encourage this AI
that is like almost like an-
Not so much an artificial intelligence
that can go back in time and kill us,
but it might be like it's like a puppy
or some sheep.
Like, how do we modify these AI things
into kind of testing their software
the way we want them to?
But under the hood,
the engine that it will be doing
to do its thing
will be Selenium or WebDriver, right?
But will people be writing Selenium tests?
Like, I'm not convinced
that people will be,
but they'll need to be able to read them
because if the AI spits out total garbage,
someone will have to go in there
and fix it.
Just like today, someone somewhere
has to go into some source code
and modify COBOL
because like the IRS or Social Security
couldn't print checks last week.
Like, that code's still there,
but most of the time,
you don't care about it.
It'll hopefully just work.
So maybe Selenium's future
is that it's like COBOL.
It's everywhere, but you don't care.
Until you don't get paid.
So I'm going to tweet that right now.
Inventor of Selenium says it's just like COBOL.
All right, thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
This has been awesome having you on.
I love the stories.
I think it's good to hear that
it's good for you not to yell at us
and find some agreement there
and point out our hyperbole.
We appreciate that.
But yeah, these stories are fantastic.
Thank you so much for volunteering
to be on our show.
Thanks.
All right.
I'm still Alan.
And I'm Brent.
Oh, and I'm Jason Huggins.
All right.
Thanks, everybody.
We'll see you next time.
Bye.